[Music]
if you couldn't tell megan fox and
machine gun kelly are engaged
it's the most talented boy in the world
the couple shared the happy news on
instagram megan posting this montage of
the big moment
[Music]
[Music]
according to the actress's caption the
proposal happened on tuesday and her
message has some other interesting
details too after she said yes megan
claims they quote drank each other's
blood
also in the caption megan alludes to the
location's special significance writing
quote in july of 2020 we set under this
banyan tree we asked for magic
somehow a year and a half later having
walked through hell together and having
laughed more than i ever imagined
possible he asked me to marry him and
just as in every lifetime before this
one and as in every lifetime that will
follow it i said yes and the couple is
getting a lot of love in the comments
kim kardashian added her congrats
writing quote so happy for you guys
i'm very shy
meanwhile mgk shared this close-up of
megan's pear-shaped diamond ring the
singer provides some backstory in the
caption explaining quote the emerald her
birthstone and the diamond my birthstone
set on two magnetic fans of thorns that
draw together as two halves of the same
soul forming the obscure heart that is
our love he's so charismatic and he's so
naturally gifted and the affection is
very mutual
as news of their engagement broke a
source told et quote mgk has been
telling his friends how megan is his
dream girl and he is always trying to
make her happy and do romantic things
for her his proposal plan was no
exception and he wanted it to be very
special the two of them are so ready and
excited to continue their journey as a
couple and create more memories together
congrats to the happy engaged couple
[Music]
you